[Musique]
bonsoir à tous début d'une nouvelle
semaine d'information locale sur et v60
18 bienvenue pour cette édition spéciale
du lundi 6 avril 2020
la crise du coronavirus et ses
conséquences sanitaires s'aggrave en
france et dans les yvelines
le colis de 19 a causé la mort de 175
personnes dans les hôpitaux du
département depuis le début de la
pandémie
d'après les derniers chiffres de santé
publique france du 5 avril soit 38
essais supplémentaires en 48 heures 909
personnes atteintes du virus sont
hospitalisés sur le territoire dont 185
placé en soins intensifs
enfin pour être complet sur le bilan
sanitaire 470 binois ont pu retourner à
leur domicile suite à l'amélioration de
leur santé et conséquences de l'épidémie
du colis de 19 la forte diminution des
consultations pour les autres
pathologies dans les cabinets de
médecine générale en raison du
confinement de la peur d'être contaminé
les patients préfèrent reporter ou
éviter un éventuel recours aux soins
médecins assurance maladie agences
régionales de santé tire la sonnette
d'alarmé
écoutez le docteur albert ouazana il est
notamment chargé du drs de médecine
générale a lu vs q n'oublions pas que à
côté de l'épidémie actuelle toutes les
pathologies continue à exister et il
faut faire face les gens continuent à
voir l infarctus continue à voir un
accident vasculaire cérébral continue
avant et pyélonéphrite continue à tomber
dans les escaliers à se fracturer les
pôles etc
enfin voilà tout existe et ne faut pas
oublier que le médecin reste disponible
pour toutes les pathologies
[Musique]
si un cabinet est équipé pour accueillir
des patients dans ces conditions
difficiles souvent ce sont des centres
de santé des maisons médicales des
cabinets de groupe qui peuvent permettre
d'accueillir des patients qui sont peut
être infecté qui sont suspects de
transmettre la maladie donc dans ces cas
là il va y avoir un parcours des
patients infectés il y aura une salle
d'attenté très préservé il y aura un
cabinet médical réservé permettant de
limiter les risques d'épidémies
téléconsultation permet de préserver
tout le monde et permet de ne pas perdre
ne pas entraîner un risque qui serait un
risque important de passer à côté de
pathologies sous jacentes pour lesquels
le patient habituellement consultent et
là il dit bah je vais rester à la maison
c'est plus prudent et et puis du coup
les signes évolué et il arrive à
consulter un petit peu plus tard et nous
ne voulons pas que ce soit trop tard une
version numérique de l'attestation de
déplacement disponible depuis ce lundi 6
avril le ministère de l'intérieur met à
disposition sur son site internet une
attestation de déplacement dérogatoire
utilisable sur tablettes et smartphones
pour rappel ce document est obligatoire
pour l'ensemble de vos sorties de
domicile comme pour la version papier
vous devez remplir le document avec les
informations suivantes identités
adresses motifs de sortie ainsi que la
date et l'heure pour faciliter le
contrôle par les forces de l'ordre
un qr code est associée à chaque
document autres dispositifs numériques
mises en place par le gouvernement la
plateforme mobilisation emploi point
gouv.fr lancé en fin de semaine dernière
un nouvel outil utilisé par pôle emploi
pour répertorier les offres dans les
secteurs dits essentiels dans ce
contexte de crise sanitaire la direction
territoriale de pôle emploi des yvelines
s'est mobilisée les images sont signés
patrick jacques de dixmude mobilisation
exceptionnelle pour l'emploi c'est le
principe de cette plateforme lancée par
le gouvernement
objectif permettre de faciliter le
recrutement dans les filières
nécessaires à la lutte contre le coc
vide dix neuf avec pôle emploi en
première ligne aujourd'hui nous nous
concentrons beaucoup de moyens sur les
offres concernant les secteurs
essentiels en contact avec les
entreprises les conseillers pôle emploi
répertorie les offres et accompagne la
démarche de recrutement tout demandeur
d'emploi ou travailleurs en chômage
partiel peut ensuite postuler sur cette
plateforme qui si nous avons les
secteurs
dis donc prioritaire par rapport à la
situation donc où nous allons pouvoir
déposer les offres des employeurs en
difficultés de recrutement voilà ça va
nous aider je l'espère à trouver des
candidats
donc ça touche voilà le des postes
d'agents de service hospitalier dans la
grande distribution auxiliaires de vie
aides soignants c'est ça peut être des
vacations d'une heure à 10 heures selon
la structure n'a vraiment besoin de tout
le personnel possible nos structures
d'aidé à domicile sont vraiment en
difficulté puisque
des personnes dépendantes ont besoin
encore ont besoin qu'on se rende chez
elle pour des ados repas pris au
médicament aux toilettes
actuellement 115 offres d'emploi sont
proposées sur la plateforme dans le
département des yvelines
battu au premier tour le maire sortant
du chéné rocancourt philippe brillault
reste malgré tout en poste pendant cette
période de crise sanitaire le conseil
d'installation de la nouvelle équipe
ayant pu se tenir
il lui appartient donc de gérer la
situation médecin au civil il nous a
ouvert les portes de son hôtel de ville
le récit de wilfrid rifi et les images
sont signés patrick jacq de mix mood en
ce début du mois d'avril c'est en tant
que chef de file d'opposition qu'elle
devrait siéger a battu par moins de cent
voix d'écart lors du premier tour avec
une participation de 38% philippe
brillault est pourtant toujours maire du
chesnay rocancourt une situation qui se
retrouvent dans plusieurs communes de
france le lendemain du 15 mars
je faisais mes cartons j'étais en train
de vider mon bureau et puis j'avais
envoyé une convocation pour faire le
premier conseil et puis le gouvernement
au dernier moment à annuler le
gouvernement a remis tous les conseils
en place avec toutes nos fonctions ou
autre qu'est ce qui va se passer demain
on ne sait pas c'est pour ça que je dis
que ça on verra après pour l'instant
traitons les gens assurons la sortie au
mois de mai juin je sais pas quand et
puis on aura le temps de parler de tout
ça chaque jour ici comme ailleurs en
france le maire doit donc gérer les
affaires courantes mais aussi et surtout
faire jouer son pouvoir de police en
utilisant les outils à sa disposition
comme la vidéoprotection ça nous permet
avec la police municipale si jamais il
ya des attroupements anormaux de pouvoir
intervenir des gens disent on voit pas
la police municipale mais on a l'oeil
sur la ville voilà donc ça ça permet à
arnaud à 2 depuis l interface est sûre
le confinement le code général des
collectivités territoriales prévoit en
effet que le premier édile puisse agir
pour prévenir et faire cesser les
maladies épidémiques au contagieuse et
cette gestion de crise pour philippe
brillault est aussi l'occasion de mettre
à profit son autre casquette celle de
médecins en supervisant par exemple cet
atelier de couture au coeur de l'hôtel
de ville où l'on fabrique des masques en
respectant au mieux les normes en
vigueur mais aussi des blues
si on a créé cet atelier ici c'est parce
qu'on est en train de mettre mettre au
point des blues pour notre ehpad pour se
protéger et donc ça permettra de mettre
une blouse comme ça dans chaque chambre
où il ya un isolement de personnes
et le soir on la lave et on emmène neuf
car la ville gère effectivement un
établissement d'hébergement pour
personnes âgées dépendantes celui des
chaînes d'or établissements de 69
chambres
le mairie intervient également en tant
que professionnels de santé donc ce
médecin coordinateur travaille du matin
au soir dans l'établissement et assure
pour le personnel pour les résidents
tout ce qui peut être la sécurité
sanitaire et le suivi je l'accompagnent
depuis maintenant une huitaine de jours
parce qu'il a besoin de souffler un peu
dimanche je les remplacer et puis on
essaye de travailler un petit peu comme
moi là je suis son son agglo
collaborateurs nous avons actuellement
quatorze résidents qui sont isolées
strictes nous avons
perdu malheureusement quatre résidents
fortes suspicions que vides pour deux et
deux confirmés qu'aux vide
pour ce qui est du personnel nous avons
des renforts
qu'ils viennent essentiellement des
crèches du personnel des crèches de la
municipalité également volontaire
commentaires sur eux et c'est par hawks
et par qui c'est des volontaires mais le
quotidien d'un maire en période de crise
sanitaire signifie aussi de s'assurer de
la continuité des services comme celui
de l'urbanisme des finances ou encore de
l'état civil
on a les naissances et les décès donc ça
ce papa qui vient alors donc il a
téléphoné il aa demandé on lui a ouvert
la porte et il est en train de déclarer
son enfant et pour toutes les questions
des administrés c'est un centre
d'accueil spécifique qui a été mis en
place
il intervient aussi auprès des personnes
isolées référencés dans le cadre du plan
canicule plateforme à l'avantagé d'une
plateforme de convergence pour toutes
les structures de solidarité qui sont
montés dans la ville dans un immeuble
dans un lotissement entre personnes ou
autre ça permet d'avoir ici une
coordination de l'ensemble nous on n'est
pas là pour se substituer à aux autres
on est là pour faire fonctionner tout ce
qui a été mis en place et d'avoir des
échanges d'informations c'est une
structure qui va évoluer dans les
semaines qui viennent parce qu'on est
certain que on va se retrouver les des
problèmes un peu psychologique des
problèmes les violences conjugales qui
peuvent aussi nous prévenir là et on met
en route
effectivement les orientations en
fonction des différentes personnes
habilitées à le faire et pour le
personnel présent volontaire comme
bénévole les principes de précaution
sanitaires sont respectées
quant aux communes et aux maires ils
devront sans doute poursuivre ses
actions jusqu'au début du mois de mai
autre type de mobilisation dans les
villes françaises la désinfection des
rues commencent à se répandre sur le
territoire l'efficacité n'est pas encore
prouvée mais à nice ou encore à menton
les communaux ont déjà tenté
l'expérience en région parisienne saint
germes en les le vésinet ou encore
elancourt se sont lancés dans cette
démarche les détails de wilfrid riffier
de patrick jacques de dixmude des hommes
en combinaison intégrale qui pulvérise
dans les rues une solution afin
d'éliminer virus et bactéries une scène
qui se retrouvent dans un nombre
croissant de communes notamment elles
ont cours ici
un arrêt de bus dans le quartier de la
clé de saint pierre on a trouvé que
c'était important de travailler sur tout
ce qui est mobile et urbain alors soit
pour les transports ou les meilleurs
d'un traditionnel bancs poubelles et
autres qui peuvent être utilisés par les
aimants courtois et on estimait qu
effectivement ça peut être une source de
propagation du virus donc on souhaite
venir nettoyer la ville qui précise
respecter les règles environnementales
effectivement une solution à base de
chlore sont des solutions qu'on utilise
déjà notamment dans des cantines des
choses comme ça qui sont adaptés qui
sont diluées dans l'eau
donc l'idée c'est de faire un premier
passage pour nettoyer le site et après
un massage effectivement à grande
envergure
donc on veut pas faire n'importe quoi
soyons vigilants
il ya suffisamment de problèmes déjà
avec ce virus
pour l'instant il ne s'agit que d'une
première phase qui ne concernent
notamment que les centres commerciaux et
les lieux encore fréquenté la réflexion
est en cours pour une opération de plus
grande envergure
la fréquence sera seul d'une fois par
semaine on est à l'hebdomadaire et on
verra en fonction de l'avancée s'il ya
nécessité de faire un peu plus une
initiative qui ne se substitue pas aux
gestes barrières mais qui pourrait
permettre en tout cas de rassurer un peu
la population
c'est officiel depuis vendredi dernier
l'examen 2020 du baccalauréat sera
validée sur la base du contrôle continu
quelles vont être les nouvelles
modalités pour les élèves évinois les
explications d'aurélie rose une scène
traditionnelle qui n'aura pas lieu cette
année en raison de l'épidémie de covin
exceptionnellement les examens de
l'éducation nationale seront évalués sur
le mode du contrôle continu
il n'y aura donc pas d'épreuves du
baccalauréat en juin prochain
seule solution pratique pour cette année
c'est s'agit bien encore une fois d'une
solution a prise à titre exceptionnel
d'insérer c'est le contrôle continu
dans l'état actuel des choses il n'est
pas possible on se pacse pas possible
d'organiser le bac normalement
au jeu trop tard habituel que va prendre
en compte le contrôle continu
les résultats obtenus lors des deux
premiers trimestres ainsi que les notes
obtenues en jouant en cas de
déconfinement les professeurs mettront
également une appréciation sur le
travail fourni pendant la période de
confinement appréciation qui sera prise
en compte par un jury de notation qui
évaluera l'assiduité le comportement de
chaque élève
une mesure qui pourrait impliquer des
inégalités selon certains syndicats
enseignants et que quand on rencontre et
nous on a des portes closes légalité
selon selon les différents
établissements les pratiques
d'évaluation
le voilà l'état d'étude des locales
donc effectivement il y aura du jury et
non en afrique pour que la transparence
au fonctionnement de ces jolies les
oraux sauront-ils maintenue pour le bac
les quelques soixante et onze mille
élèves yvelinois pourront passer un oral
de rattrapage début juillet s'ils
obtiennent une moyenne comprise entre 8
et 9,9 sur 20 concernant les épreuves
anticipées de français en première les
cris est annulé mais l'épreuve orale
devrait bel et bien être maintenus fin
juin ou début juillet
et avant de nous quitter recours sur la
performance de matisse poirier a 19 ans
cette habitante de neauphle-le-château a
couru un marathon ce dimanche 5 avril en
plein confinement mais rassurez-vous
c'était dans son jardin 3h45 avec plus
de 2000 tours écoutez le les deux les
deux premières heures à l'est et puis
tout a dérapé voilà la troisième heure
c'était compliqué de passer à la
troisième heure puis après tout s'est
joué au mental sur le sur la dernière
partie de la cour jusqu'à met 3h45
c'était assez compliqué mais j'ai réussi
et c'est ça qui est sympa je pense que
c'est surtout le l'espace confiné et
puis way la monotonie en fait du terrain
qui a fait que pendant 3 heures 45 j'ai
tourné en rond entre guillemets ça
c'était assez compliqué satire est
vachement sur les articulations dans les
virages parce que je tournais j'essayais
de sang j'ai changé de sens au fur et à
mesure de la course pour pas que ça tire
toujours au même endroit
donc ça c'était vraiment très difficile
un défi à réaliser pour le compte de
l'association mécénat chirurgie
cardiaque elle vient en aide aux enfants
de pays du tiers monde pour réaliser des
opérations de chirurgie cardiaque en
france pour faire des dons vous pouvez
vous rendre sur le lien du site internet
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
merci de nous avoir suivis pour cette
édition spéciale
prenez soin de vous en restant à votre
domicile et on se quitte sur ces images
du marathon de matisse poirier belle
soirée sur télé 78
[Musique]